digamos que nos dan la fórmula molecular
c3 h 8
y nos piden dibujar una estructura de
lewis aquí a la izquierda hay una
estructura de louis posible que tiene
dicha fórmula molecular de hecho si si
te das cuenta hay 3 carbonos hay 3
carbonos hay un oxígeno y hay 8
hidrógenos 12345678 muy bien y como toda
estructura de louis que de hecho
deberíamos remarcar aquí que esto es una
estructura de luís como toda estructura
de louis en realidad tiene todos los
enlaces explícitos y puede llevarnos
mucho tiempo dibujarlo así que podríamos
tratar de representar esta molécula en
distintas formas por ejemplo no sé si
partimos de este carbono particular
podríamos representarlo de este lado y
ahora nos vamos a ir fijando en algunos
grupos por ejemplo aquí tenemos un h que
está unido al carbono entonces agregamos
pero unido estamos simplificando todo
esto y estamos poniendo también a las
dos parejas de electrones solitarios que
acompañan al oxígeno ahora también
tenemos un hidrógeno verdad que está
unido al carbono entonces ponemos un
hidrógeno ahora nos vamos a fijar no en
el carbono sino en este carbono y sus
tres hidrógenos verdad que estamos
ahorita marcando con magenta muy bien
entonces este carbono estará unido a un
grupo ch3 muy bien ahí tenemos un
ch 3 muy bien
también podríamos hacerlo igual que con
el lado izquierdo verdad aquí tenemos un
carbono que está unido a tres hidrógenos
entonces este carbono está unido a uno
h 3 verdad donde por supuesto este
carbono magenta se refiere a este y este
carbono subrayado en azul se refiere a
este y este de enmedio es el rojo
entonces a esta representación que
acabamos de hacer de dibujar digamos se
le conoce como una fórmula o estructura
semi desarrollada semi desarrollada muy
bien y en realidad si nos fijamos tienen
la misma información que la estructura
de louis que teníamos del lado izquierdo
es exactamente la misma molécula solo es
una forma distinta de representar las
digamos le estamos representando sin
poner todos los enlaces lo cual lo hace
bastante cómodo pero todavía podríamos
digamos condensar lo más verdad por
ejemplo si ahora nos fijamos en el
carbono nuevamente que tenemos en rojo
vamos a fijarnos
en este carbono que quizás lo tape mucho
nos fijamos en este carbono podemos
observar lo siguiente este carbono está
unido a un ch 3 que corresponde al ch 3
que encontramos acá y está unido también
a otros ch3 que es el ch 3 que podemos
ubicar de este otro lado verdad entonces
lo que podemos ver es que si este
carbono en rojo lo representamos aquí
entonces este carbono está unido a 2
ch 3 entonces ponemos ch 3 y ponemos un
21 por el magenta y otro por el azul
ahora bien que otra cosa tenemos este
carbono está unido a un hidrógeno está
unido a este hidrógeno y también está
unido a un h verdad entonces ponemos que
este carbono está unido a un hidrógeno
o h entonces si te das cuenta en esta
estructura que es la que se conoce como
estructura condensada condensada no hay
enlaces así que uno debe deducir dónde
van los enlaces a partir de la fórmula
muy bien ahora vamos a irnos en sentido
contrario digamos que ahora iniciamos
con alguna forma fórmula condensada y
vamos a pasarlo a una fórmula semi
desarrollada para llegar a la estructura
de louis completa ok entonces digamos
que tenemos
ch 33 tenemos 13 h 3
o
h 3 muy bien entonces esta es nuestra
fórmula condensada y ahora vamos a
tratar de hacer una fórmula semi
desarrollada nuevamente vamos a partir
con un carbono que estamos circular más
bien subrayando con rojo vamos a partir
de él y vamos a ponerlo de este lado
digamos en medio muy bien ese carbono en
realidad es el que habíamos subrayado
con rojo y aquí podemos observar que
este carbono está unido a tres se h tres
verdad tenemos tres de ellos entonces
hay que unirlo
ch 3 aquí está el primero aquí está el
segundo y acá va a estar el tercero muy
bien tenemos 3 c h 3 y además está unido
a un oxígeno verdad entonces este
carbono está unido a un oxígeno y
podemos observar que este carbono ya
tiene 8 electrones alrededor verdad
entonces ahí tenemos que ya cumple la
regla del octeto y este oxígeno ahora
está unido a un grupo o más bien a un ch
3 verdad tenemos que estar unido a un
h3 y para que cumpla también la regla
del octeto hay que poner dos parejas de
electrones solitarios verdad entonces ya
tenemos aquí nuestra fórmula semi
desarrollada verdad ahora vamos a tratar
de pasarlo a una estructura de louis
bien bien desarrollada digamos ok
nuevamente podemos empezar con este
carbono en rojo verdad vamos a ponerlo
digamos por aquí
ahí está el carbono que representamos en
rojo y este carbono está unido con un
ch3 que y entonces ese carbono estará
unido a un carbono que a su vez está
unido a tres hidrógenos verdad este de
aquí está representando al ch 3 que
circulamos con magenta ahora vamos a ver
qué pasa por ejemplo con este que
tenemos aquí que estoy circulando en
verde es otro ch3 entonces el carbono
está unido a otro carbono que a su vez
está unido a tres hidrógenos y estamos
apretando aquí porque ya no hay mucho
espacio
entonces este ch3 en realidad es este
que habíamos circulado con verde y
tenemos otro ch3 verdad tenemos otros
ch3 vamos a unir este carbono con otro
carbono que a su vez está unido con tres
hidrógenos y entonces ese ch3
corresponde a este que habíamos
circulado con azul ahora también tenemos
al carbono unido con el oxígeno y sus
dos parejas de electrones solitarios y
que a su vez está unido a uno
ch 3 verdad entonces vamos a poner
unido con tres hidrógenos muy bien
quizás debería corregir esto está el
enlace y tenemos el hidrógeno entonces
este sh 3 corresponde a este que ya
habíamos circulado con rosas muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos la estructura del
louis y esta es una habilidad muy
importante la habilidad de poder pasar
de fórmulas o estructuras condensadas a
la estructura de louis o en sentido
contrario y la de louis se usa
principalmente para moléculas pequeñas
cuando hay moléculas grandes suelen
usarse otro tipo de estructuras que se
conocen como estructuras de enlace línea
que veremos en próximos vídeos